[Music]
it's a billion dollar mystery that could
cost the state of South Carolina tens of
millions in October someone bought a
winning Mega Millions ticket worth more
than one and a half billion dollars it
was the second largest lottery jackpot
in US history but the winner has not
come forward and now has less than 60
days left to claim the prize Anna Werner
shows us the theories and fall out in
this lotto mystery I'm trying to figure
out who won the Mega Millions jackpot
it's crazy that we have a winner
excitement and intrigue spread across
South Carolina after it was revealed in
October the winning ticket of the more
than 1.5 billion dollar jackpot was
bought at this store in the small town
of simpsonville the announcement was met
with celebration but four months later
no one has claimed the prize people are
still asking about the winner who it who
it could be
if the price goes unclaimed by the April
19th deadline the 1.5 billion dollars
will be redistributed to the 44 states
along with DC and the US Virgin Islands
that take part in the Mega Millions the
state of South Carolina could lose out
on 61 million dollars of income tax
revenue from the winner the biggest Mega
Millions jackpot to go unclaimed was a
68 million dollar prize in 2002 the
winning ticket was sold in New York
included in the fallout Simpson bills
now famous KC Mart would not be awarded
the $50,000 bonus for selling the
winning ticket if a prize goes unclaimed
he's hoping that the winner shows up so
that the store gets its part for CBS
this morning I'm Anna Warner
time is running out to claim that money
a lot of money here it's in my jacket
pocket song yeah yeah you're the winner